representatives from nearly 200 nations
have converged on Madrid to try and push
towards hope although it has been a
bumpy start
we have sleepwalked past the point of no
return
GOP rising the health and safety of
everyone on this planet do we really
want to be remembered as the generation
that worried its head in the sand gets
fiddled while the planet burns the other
option is the path of hope a passive
resolve of sustainable solutions a path
where more fossil fuels remain where
they should be in the ground and where
we are on the way to carbon neutrality
by 2050 to do anything less will be a
betrayal of our entire human family and
all the generations to come the city had
just weeks to prepare for the event
after Brazil and then Chile pulled out
of hosting the delegates gathered here
are trying to sort out two really
difficult problems agreeing on the rules
for global carbon markets and deciding
how to compensate poorer countries
who've suffered loss and damage
associated with climate change they are
the final pieces of the Paris agreement
but no matter the will and the ambition
finding consensus on this scale is
always hard to do and there is
acknowledgement it may not be possible
will they be totally resolved in the
next two weeks probably not to be
brutally honest you can take some good
steps towards that that'll be great
talk needs to be translated into action
it's a national level at a community
level and that's how we'll kind of match
the talk with the action the economical
guess is there we have the fiscal case
we need a lot more of the political
support into this and the science is
there so the elements are
apart from the political will apart from
the political world that is taking very
long everything's being negotiated as
more and more evidence emerges that the
impact of climate change on our world
the Arctic warming the Amazon burning
and scientists sounding the alarm over
the massive gap between government
commitments and what is actually
required to limit the worst of what is
to come
Madrid is supposed to set the stage for
a crucial 12 months of climate action
but achieving its goals over the next
two weeks is going to be a real
challenge
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in Madrid